DAN PETERSON: So, good
morning everyone.
Sorry, we're running a
little bit late here.
The good news is that
we still have the full
hour for this session.
So, if you didn't hear already,
this session is being moved
around a little bit, so that
you do 11:15 to 12:15 for
this particular session.
So, I'm Dan Peterson.
We have a fireside chat here.
Just a chat about all
things going on with Wave.
I hope you liked our
announcement in the
keynote this morning.
I think we'll start things off
here, just to introduce
everybody on the panel, and
then we'll be sort of switching
between our questions and
moderators, as well
00:00:42,726 --> 00:00:42,16
as questions live.
So, I'm Dan Peterson Product
Manager on the Federation
of API things.
And, well Lars.
We have a few mics.
ALAN GREEN: My name is Alan
Green, I'm an Engineer on
Wave, and I'm most working
on Enterprise things.
PAMELA FOX: My name is Pamela
Fox, and I work on Google Wave
API Developer Relations.
DOUWE OSINGA: I'm Douwe, I'm
the TL on the API Team.
JOCHEN BEKMANN: I'm
Jochen Bekmann, and work
primarily on Federation.
So Lars would you like to kick
things off a little bit with
rehashing some of the
announcements in case
people missed it.
LARS RASMUSSEN: Yes.
First I should just say thank
you to all of you guys for all
the amazing things you've
built over the past years.
And all of the feedback
we've gotten from you.
That's been absolutely the
best part of the last year.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So, just to rehash the new
things we're announcing today.
First and foremost where
opening up Wave to everyone.
So, you no longer need an
invitation to use Wave.
This is true both for
individuals and for
organizations that
use Google Apps.
If you have a Google
Apps domain, you can
go and turn on Wave.
I think we're rolling it out
during the morning here.
So, it might not quite affect
your control panel yet,
but it will be there soon.
And, then with the API,
we're rolling out a
bunch of new things.
For starters, we're starting
with a system that means Robots
no longer have to live on App
Engine, they can live
anywhere on the web.
We're adding Media and
Attachment features to both
our Robot and Media APIs.
We are starting a new API, we
call it the Wave Data API, that
is designed to let you build
things like notifiers, and even
light weight clients, in
particular for mobile devices.
And, then we're adding a bunch
of smaller things, like a bunch
of new hooks for your
extensions to better
integrate into our client.
And, then on the protocol
track, we are open sourcing
more of our production
code today.
I don't have the hit yet.
who's in charge of
the hitting --
JOCHEN BEKMANN: A summary
has been released, and
there's more coming.
LARS RASMUSSEN:
OK.
00:02:59,758 --> 00:02:59,138
Yes.
The lines of code are trickling
in to the open source
repository, its own particular,
the editor in our client, which
by far is the hardest part to
write on the Wave client.
We've open sourced that.
We're in the process of
open sourcing that today.
I think, Jochen you can
nod if I'm telling
the right thing here.
Where, in the open source
repository, it's going to be
wrapped in a very simple Wave
plan, which speaks the
beginnings of a client server
protocol between the
lightweight web client and are
open source server
called FedOne.
And, we also are putting up the
beginnings of a white paper
describing that protocol.
The idea is, and this is one of
the tough requested features,
that you guys will be able to
build a web client from
scratch, using our open source
code or not, that you can put
on top of different Wave
systems that speak
this protocol.
Which, of course,
will include ours.
And, so that's the
news from today.
The primary reason that we're
opening out Wave now is that
while when we started the
invitation only preview, it was
clearly still, and we knew
this, it was pretty still
buggy, it was slow, it has a
bunch of usability features.
And, what we've measured in the
feedback from people actively
using it over the past couple
of months, more and more we
hear people actually
finding Wave make the more
productive and work.
And, that's why we're
opening up today.
And, in particular, the use
cases where Wave really shines
is for groups of people all
adopting Wave at the same time,
and using Wave as a primary
tool for coordinating the work,
for collaborating on it, for
writing their design documents,
for tracking their tasks, for
all those kinds of things.
Let me just stop there,
and we'll take questions.
DAN PETERSON: Maybe to kick
things off live, how about
we take the first question
from the audience?
Wait, there's a mic
here in the middle.
Or, if there's nobody super
eager, we can jump into the
moderator, because were are
geeks and have been
using Wave a lot.
You have a mic?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
We've just been looking at
the new data APIs that
you've have announced.
We've noticed at the
moment that their still
lockdown to sandbox.
You know, what's the timescale
that you are working on to
release it to the main
preview or collabs.
DOUWE OSINGA: Sorry
Data API, was it?
AUDIENCE: The new Data API
that you just released today.
The inbox sort of access.
DOUWE OSINGA: I'm pretty
sure that works.
AUDIENCE: Is that on
preview as well
as.
DOUWE OSINGA: You mean the,
sorry, do you mean the Data
API or the Robot liberation?
AUDIENCE: The Data API.
DOUWE OSINGA: The Data
API should work on --
DAN PETERSON: Yes.
So, the Data API is enabled
on both the sandbox instance
and the external instance?
DOUWE OSINGA: I
sincerely hope so.
DAN PETERSON: OK.
If it's not, it will
be fixed, quickly.
00:05:56,818 --> 00:05:56,338
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
PAMELA FOX: The new Chrome
notifier extension is actually
using the Wave Date API.
And, you can use it with your
Google Wave preview account.
I've been using it for
the last 24 hours.
It's been riveting.
So, that kind of proves that.
If there's a mistake in the
docs, I might have written
them a bit late last night.
So, we can take a look,
and check on that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
On the new, the Editor that's
been open sourced, do I need
to use GWT to use that?
DAN PETERSON: The new
web client is uses GWT,
yeah, so its Java code
would be releasing.
AUDIENCE: Hi, will
there be some sort of
federation liberation?
JOCHEN BEKMANN: Federation
is liberated, could
you elaborate please?
AUDIENCE: So, that we
could federate with
a real Wave account?
I thought at least they
was liberated only to the
extent to the sandbox.
JOCHEN BEKMANN: Right.
OK.
So, yes, we don't have it
on GoogleWave.com, we have
it on WaveSandbox.com.
And, yes, we hope
they will be one.
We don't have an exact
timeline, but hopefully
it will be soon.
UNKNOWN: Months.
DAN PETERSON: So the thing with
federating on Google Wave, it
is something that treally
want to do soon.
Unfortunately, there's a
lot of work to be done
at the model level.
Because, it's rather
complicated if we were to be
sort of changing the model
after the fact of the
that port being open.
And, so it is something we want
to address, but we also need to
sort of keep iterating through
the use cases of the model.
So, we can make sure there
aren't going to be major
changes after that point, or
at least they're backwards
compatible and it
can be graceful.
JOCHEN BEKMANN: And, the
major problem is that all
of the changes in Waves are
signed cryptographically.
It's really hard to do
migration with a distributive
system where, you know, you
can't ask different servers
to migrate their data.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have a plan for
developing Gadget API?
There are so much ways where
it can [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
For instance, accessing the
parent iFrame, parent window,
having those cool name pages
inside a gadget, and so on.
What are your plans
for updating Gadget
API in Google 8?
00:08:14,558 --> 00:08:14,464
DOUWE OSINGA: Gadget API?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DOUWE OSINGA: What
would you like to see?
AUDIENCE: First, I would like
to access the parent scroll,
the parent window scroll.
Because, I'm now doing crazy
hacks just to get the
parent window scroll Like
positioning text area
and setting focus to it.
So, the browser can scroll.
And, now I implemented name
pages on my own, but they are
not so good, and [INAUDIBLE]
needed.
DOUWE OSINGA: Yeah, we
should totally do that.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
What are your plans about it?
PAMELA FOX: Yeah, We've heard
that there's definitely been a
lot of people who are running
into issues with Gadgets, when
they have Gadgets that take
up like a large canvas.
And, there's
scrolling involved.
And, there's panning.
And, so the things we're
looking into is stuff like
letting Gadgets full
screen themselves.
Right.
And, also giving Gadgets,
you know, more control
over where the Wave is.
So, I don't think we
necessarily give you access
to the parent, because
that's kind of dangerous.
But, we would give you a method
that says like you need to
scroll to this position now.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Is there
approximate schedule.
When can we expect it?
Next year or next month?
PAMELA FOX: Months.
AUDIENCE: Months.
OK.
And, according to
security issue.
As a user I'm a bit scared that
Gadgets can make any request
to any public server.
So, it can transfer any of my
personal information that
Google Wave, Gadget API
they provide a lot of
information of me.
So, is there any ability for
the user to control what
information can be transferred.
DOUWE OSINGA: Yes.
So we have plans, and I'm
afraid we have been saying
that for too long to do
something about that.
Basically there is this other
project in Google that allows
you to lockdown JavaScripts.
And, so we will start using
that for the subset of
the gadget, where this
would be a concern.
And, for the other ones,
we would have a sort
of opt-in scheme.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
00:10:25,14 --> 00:10:25,084
PAMELA FOX: Yeah.
That project is called Taha.
So, if want you could open
search project so you
can actually check out.
It's being used for
various Gadgets.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And what will be response for
me as a Gadget developer.
So, first my Gadget is
gathering Google Wave IDs
and storing it in an
external SQL server.
So, what will be response to
my Gadget if user decided to
protect this information.
DOUWE OSINGA: Well, then
you wouldn't be able
to talk to children.
AUDIENCE: Ah-ha.
So, I will be just able to
make any adjunct requests
to external servers?
DOUWE OSINGA: Well, so, we
haven't really settled down
on what exactly what
this API will be.
But, I think vaguely our plans
are to have a sort of a more
open thing, where you can do
all kinds of things, but
where you have to first get
permission from the user.
And, have a lockdown API where
the user doesn't have to open.
But, lets you build as a
developer, small controls
that, you know, don't need
to make these outside calls.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
this third question.
I remember that actually why I
need access -- I'm finished --
why I need to access the
server, just I need to store
some information for user,
not for Blimp, not for
Gadget but for user.
Is there plans for -- I need
storage for user users.
DOUWE OSINGA: Yes, we
have actually silently
00:11:41,7 --> 00:11:41,16
promoting them.
00:11:42,54 --> 00:11:42,34
PAMELA FOX: Oh yeah.
00:11:43,4 --> 00:11:43,34
Sorry.
I didn't do them.
OK.
So, we did launch Private
Gadget State API a few weeks.
It's in the reference.
So, you can actually store
information pertinent to the
user, like maybe notes that
the user has left in Gadget
that's only for them, or
personal preferences.
So, you can start using
that for a few use cases.
AUDIENCE: Is it Wave wide?
So --
PAMELA FOX: No, that one, the
private Gadget State API is
just per that Gadget instance.
So, you're also asking about
a Wave-wide thing, because
--
AUDIENCE: I need to store
some personal things.
PAMELA FOX: Yeah, So, I
think we could look into a
Wave-wide settings as well.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean generally a
Wave has more work to do
in the settings area.
And, once we see more settings
for different parts of Wave, we
can bring that into Gadgets
and Robots as well.
AUDIENCE:
OK.
Thank you.
DAN PETERSON: Yeah, I do want
to make sure to jump into the
moderator questions as well.
So, let's grab one from there.
So, is there a plan to add
capability for Wave to allow
contributions to Wave by
non-Wave users through
email or IM service when
requested by a Wave user?
Is there a plan to add
capabilities for Wave users to
allow contributions to Wave by
non-Wave users through
email or IM service?
LARS RASMUSSEN: Yeah.
So, we are working on a few
more email things ourselves,
so already you can get
email notification
when a Wave changes.
We're just about to launch a
feature where you can add an e
mail address to a Wave as well.
And, then some content from the
Wave will go out in an email
with a link pointing
back to that Wave.
And, sometime later, I'm not
going to give any particular
time frame, but sometime later
we'll make it possible to
reply to those emails.
And, have the your reply
grafted into the Wave.
I think it's already possible
to have interactions in various
ways between email and Wave
written by extension
developers.
I saw someone wearing a
Mr-Ray t-shirt here.
You can check out
extensions like that.
And, maybe get inspired
by that as well.
Yeah, Mr-Ray actually lets
people respond just by a
statically rendered Wave
that they get a link
to in their email.
And, so, they don't have
to be Wave users at all.
So, I used it for communicating
with some of my friends
who didn't have Wave.
So, if you want to check that
out, the Wave to people,
they'll be at the Wave
sandbox tomorrow.
There he goes, there he is.
And, they created Mr- Ray.
So, they have some ideas
about, you know, what
that that looks like.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I just wanted
to add after a September 30th
preview, we spend a lot of time
talking to our user surveys,
our users doing usability
studies, trying to figure out
what people wanted from Wave.
And, the top two categories we
either wan to see our Waves
in Gmail, or we want to
manage our email in Wave.
How many of you guys want that?
Which one?
Both?
[LAUGHTER]
We want everyone to know that
we'd be very happy to have your
Waves wherever you want them.
Like we, you know, we
saw the Buzz launch.
And, Buzz started out as a
product integrated into Gmail.
And, we'd be very happy if
Waves were inside of Gmail too.
But, it's a significant
amount of engineering work.
And, we've been focused on
the Waves experience itself,
and making Waves great.
But, there is Gmail Apps, and
we're hoping that we can launch
some cool Apps that would let
us experiment with different
Waves to integrate into
other Google products.
And, see what users like, and
what sort of things they
mean by integration.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Going back to the Gadget API,
one other thing that would be
very useful for us is the
ability to have a Gadget take
the user to a different
Wave by its Wave ID.
DOUWE OSINGA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean we're
actually doing that now with an
ugly URL hacker that assumes
the structure of the like
restored Wave calling thin.
But, you know, that doesn't
seem like something we
will rely on long term.
DOUWE OSINGA: No.
But, I'm aware.
And, you know, we'll add this.
And, this is, I think, you
know, we need to look at in a
wider thing a sort of stuff, a
Window management sort of stuff
that Gadget should have.
But, definitely.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And, the other thing is just
now with Wave being opened to
everybody, does that mean that
like people's Wave addresses
will now be Gmail.com
instead of GoogleWave?
PAMELA FOX: No.
There's still at
GoogleWave.com, but there's
a one-to-one mapping.
So, on Stephanie@Gmail.com, I'm
also Stephanie@GoogleWave.com.
And, so, as of today anyone
can sign in with their
existing Gmail account.
You know, they don't have to
put an actual GoogleWave.com
extension on sign in page.
So, there's a one-to-one
mapping with those accounts.
DAN PETERSON: OK.
And, when you add a participant
to Wave, you can actually type
-- it will work you
out at Gmail.com.
It will re-resolve it
at GoogleWave.com
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great, yeah, that was
the main question.
Okay, thank you.
DAN PETERSON: So, got another
question from moderator.
Is progress being made
on the mobile front?
LARS RASMUSSEN: So, I think the
biggest progress is that these
guys launching Data API, that
lets others build Liferay
clients, or mobile.
We are a little bit behind with
getting the full Wave client
to work on mobile devices.
You can see how far we are if
you have a late model iPhone,
or a late model Android.
Actually, try and go to
Wave.Google.com, and you'll
see a thing saying that
we don't support it.
Try clicking through, and
then you'll see exactly
how far we are.
PAMELA FOX: And, once again,
the Wave 2 developers created a
an Android App called WaveUp,
that let's you view
Wave and Android.
Right now, using the Robot,
but I expect you to port
that the Data APIs tonight.
So, check it out tomorrow.
AUDIENCE: Hi guys.
Thanks for your time today.
Two parter.
One, is could you talk a little
bit about the platform
strategies as it relates to
other Enterprise portals,
like Liferay, for example?
And, also if you have any
plans in terms of SSO
integration support?
LARS RASMUSSEN: I'm sorry, your
first question was about how?
AUDIENCE: So, how -- are there
any plans, has there been any
thought around how Wave
services could be integrated
with, or might replace or
compete with other Enterprise
portal platforms that are used
for integrating systems
in portal-like fashion?
LARS RASMUSSEN: I would say no.
We don't have any plans
in that regard just yet.
What was your second question?
AUDIENCE: The follow on is, are
there any plans for single sign
on support standards, like Cast
or SiteMinder or OpenID,
potentially to be integrated so
that users could use other
credentials to get
into the system?
LARS RASMUSSEN: I say no.
I don't think that's something
we have plans for yet.
So, No.
JOCHEN BEKMANN: So, what I
would say is that the
Federation product allows you
to have your own subversion,
and you extend it.
As far as supporting OpenID,
we have a very light way to
authentication mechanism that
we currently use for these
client that we will
be releasing.
However, anyone can take the
code that is out there, all
done some OpenID support,
and you're ready to go.
This is still early days.
00:19:04,52 --> 00:19:04,3
You know, fairly
experimental code.
Hopefully it will grow into
something that we'll be able to
support this on wider platform.
AUDIENCE: So, there's nothing
that would preclude somebody
from using another
authentication later,
on top of Wave?
JOCHEN BEKMANN: Would be fine.
I mean, the server-to-server
sides has full support with,
you know, certificates
between domains.
And, it's up to domain, the
provided, to make sure that
their users authenticate it.
Authenticate to their
specification, so that
OpenID, whatever is fine.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
There's one more --
STEPHANIE HANNON:
Wait, there's Dr.
00:19:36,72 --> 00:19:36,48
Wave, Dr.
Wave, ouuuuhh.
AUDIENCE: You've got Dr.
Wave up there?
That's awesome.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I know.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: That's
another guy, I met him before.
It's -- So, you can actually
do single sign on using
your Google Apps domain.
You can set up single
sign on with that.
Announcements, Wave can be
associated with your domain.
You can, therefore, do it that.
If you're interested.
The other thing is we
have a talk tomorrow
about Google Wave.
In the Enterprise we're going
to be talking with sales
forces as well to show some
of their integrations.
But, I think, the other thing
we're going to be talking about
more is how you can use the new
active API with Robots to
actually pull data from
other systems in Wave.
To try to make it more
the kind of portal you
were talking about.
AUDIENCE: Thanks guys.
I appreciate it.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Sure.
DAN PETERSON: So, there's a
question from the moderator.
Is there already a way for
Wave users to embed their
own moderator series and
Wave like you did here?
PAMELA FOX: So, we created a
few special Gadgets for the
I/O Waves, and one of those
was a Google moderator.
So, right now, the Gadget is
kind of specialized for I/O,
you know, has a few
things, hard coded.
But, we're working on both open
sourcing it, and also sticking
in the gallery so other
people can put moderator
Gadgets in their Waves.
That's an easy way to ask
questions, and sync it back
to the moderator back end.
AUDIENCE: Will Gmail contextual
Gadgets work in Wave?
DAN PETERSON: So, I think that
the set of Gadget features
involved there is slightly
different, and so I don't think
they'll work right
out of the box.
We should investigate
that more.
DOUWE OSINGA: I'm pretty sure
as Gadgets they would work, but
we don't have the partnering
matching setup to do it,
but you can probably.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I want to
make sure we understood
what you meant.
Do you mean how when you have
a UPS number or an address
inside of a Gmail?
Do you mean how there's
certain text we recognize in
Gmail, we show kind of --
AUDIENCE:
[INAUDIBLE]
DAN PETERSON: So, I can't quite
tell if the question is if
somebody were to build it for
Gmail's contact inbox, or if
somebody were building
it for Wave.
Which direction are
you trying to go?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAN PETERSON: Absolutely.
PAMELA FOX: So, you think the
basic idea of contextual
Gadgets from what I see it, is
that it's recognizing something
in your email, and doing
something smart with it.
So, this is something that
Robots can do today.
You can actually -- we just put
the documentation out for regex
hook, which means that if it
recognizes a pattern, it'll
give you a little light bulb.
And, say do you want to
run this extension.
Right.
Add that an extension, and then
that extension does something
with that bit of content.
Right.
So, that's a similar
experience.
There, we're just
triggering a regex hook.
But, in the future, I'd imagine
getting the trigger on other
kind of hooks, like you know,
we found an address or
some other piece of data.
00:23:07,578 --> 00:23:07,298
Like that.
And, I think the development
strategy is going
00:23:10,26 --> 00:23:10,08
to be different.
Because, we are two entirely
different environment.
But, I think the user
experience is fairly similar.
Its just being smart about
finding stuff in your content.
And, giving the user something
that they can do with it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PAMELA FOX: Well, I'm sure
we both use the Gadget API.
So, that part.
I think the part that's
different is the non-Gadget
part, which is how you're
actually doing the matching,
and adding it on,
and all of that.
DAN PETERSON: At the
base layer, it is
the same Gadget API.
It's just that there are
different features involved.
And, then the different sort
of processing mechanisms.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I just want
to stress that all 8 of us
are just off the plane from
Sydney, and anyone who follows
a Wave, know that we kind of
work independently from
the rest of Google.
And, that mean sometimes
we aren't on the leading
edge of things that other
product teams are doing.
But, we can definitely answer
more details around this.
We can learn more about the
Gmail contextual stuff, and put
it in our developer help form.
Right Pamela?
00:24:10,24 --> 00:24:10,18
PAMELA FOX: Yeah, sure.
Yes.
STEPHANIE HANNON: We can
put more detail there.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I got
a couple questions.
First of all, the sort of
Robot to robot interaction.
Is that coming, are we going
to see it anytime soon.
DOUWE OSINGA: It's
a little tricky.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DOUWE OSINGA: So, yeah, the
question was Robot to the Robot
communication, and what we're
going to do about that?
PAMELA FOX: Right now Robots
can actually hear events
from other robots.
00:24:41,996 --> 00:24:41,9
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DOUWE OSINGA:
The intent behind it is
to avoid ugly loops.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
00:24:47,778 --> 00:24:47,598
DOUWE OSINGA: Right.
AUDIENCE: Well obviously yeah.
Would it be possible to have
like a maximum recursion
depth, or something.
So that we could still
communicate through the Wave
using robots, but obviously
not get into an ugly loop.
DOUWE OSINGA: Anything is
possible, but -- it's
somewhat tricky to solve.
So, we have to way it against
other feature requests.
You make a lot of noise and
build an Android App and stuff.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah.
The second question is now that
you sort of opened up to the,
you know, more APIs to the
inbox sort of integrating
more tightly with users.
Are we going to see the ability
to be able to proxy for proper
users, so I can send a message
from a robot using my actual
account into a Wave?
DOUWE OSINGA: You mean write
access to the Data API or --
AUDIENCE: No.
So with the Robot at the
moment, you've got the
option to proxy for.
So you can say I'm
proxying for this user.
DOUWE OSINGA: Yes.
00:25:54,74 --> 00:25:54,34
AUDIENCE: But,
will it be possible to a
proxy for an actual Wave
user?
Well, so if you have the auth
of integration stuff from the
user, then your Robot can just
use that stuff to sign it
outgoing request and it will
be proxying for that user.
AUDIENCE: Oh brilliant.
That's with the new API?
00:26:12,46 --> 00:26:12
Yeah.
We're a little unsure when
we'll have the ability to
robots to write on behalf of
the user but that will be soon.
AUDIENCE: Sweet.
OK.
Thank you.
DAN PETERSON: A common
theme of weeks or months.
So, let's grab a question
from moderator.
Are there any plans for
integrating Google Wave with
more features from Docs?
Sorry there is little of a URL
escaping problem with our
moderator Gadget which is
something we're working on.
Google Wave and Google Docs
is sort of the question of
integration opportunities.
LARS RASMUSSEN: So, I think
you'll see fairly soon it's
just the ability to convert
between the two products.
Is the person who asked
the question in the room?
DAN PETERSON: I know this
is from the Wave so
I'm not entirely sure.
LARS RASMUSSEN: They might
still be in the room though.
I'm just wondering which
particular feature the
person is thinking about.
OK.
They're not here.
PAMELA FOX: So,
basically, export sync,
that's, you know --
DAN PETERSON: So we're working
on exporting and printing Wave.
And that you'll
see within weeks.
Including exporting
over to Google Docs.
They have better formatting
features that Google Wave has.
So it will be
collaborated on content.
In Wave you'll be
able to export
it over there.
To better formatting for
printing and so on.
DAN PETERSON: Pamela you want
to mention Fairy as well?
PAMELA FOX: Yeah.
Once again there is an
extension that you can
use today to export and
sync to Google Docs.
And it just uses the
Google Docs Data API.
It let's you authenticate
and then save to there.
I just used it this morning for
exporting something to Docs,
so I could do a little more
formatting and print it out.
That's called Fairy and
you can find it in the
extensions Gallery.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I'm just
going to ask Lars the tough
question which I think
was implicit in there.
Which is a few weeks ago Google
Docs launched a really cool
feature of live typing,
similar to Wave.
And, are these products
on a similar path?
What's the future?
Go.
LARS RASMUSSEN: I don't know.
I have much better
tough questions.
Yes.
So, we are actually working
very closely with the Docs
team to make the live
typing work over in Docs.
The two parts that still have
quite a different focus.
Right.
So it means Wave is a place
that, you know, used to
coordinate all of your work.
It's much more about
communication and collaboration
in a single space.
Whereas the Docs team our focus
is mostly on being able to
produce high fidelity documents
for printing, for exploring and
importing to and from other
document formats like
Works and PDF and so on.
The question of how tightly
we should integrate the two
products in the future, is
something that we're starting
to talk to them about.
I think, and this is the way
Google operates in general.
We really want to
hear from you guys.
Just like we were asking you
earlier whether a Wave should
live inside of Gmail.
And you could imagine that over
time all of those formatting
features are available inside
of Google Wave or maybe
the other way around.
But all of the communication
features of Wave are
inside Google Docs.
We really truly don't know yet.
And, so if you have
opinions don't be shy
to share them with us.
DAN PETERSON: So the next
question is an interesting one.
What are the Google Wave
Teams thoughts on long-term
archive issues of Wave?
I'm concerned that a Wave using
Gadget heavily will become
unintelligible a few years down
the line, when the Gadget
provider goes bust, or there's
incompatibility issues.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: So, this is
actually something that a lot
of businesses bring
up with us as well.
Making sure their sort
of data sticks around.
Some of the things we are doing
-- eventually you will be able
to export to other formats,
such as PDF, etc.
So, we've looked into being
able to do appropriate
renderings of Gadgets
in those formats.
And, so if this is something
that you're concerned about
making sure you have archive,
searchable copies of
everything, a lot of businesses
do that sort of thing where
they export everything to PDF
or some other format
periodically.
You know we obviously can't
control what the Gadget
developers do in terms of
either going to, you know,
keep their Gadgets around.
That sort of thing.
But, the other thing that we're
looking for -- and I'm only
assuming his question is geared
towards business usage.
For businesses, a lot of times
what they tend to do, they'll
tend to make internal versions
of Gadgets specifically
for that reason.
So, they don't have to
worry about if something
changes on the outside.
DAN PETERSON: Any more on that
question, or we can take
another one from moderator?
Alright.
What plans are there for
getting more people
interested in using Wave?
LARS RASMUSSEN: So I guess
we've done probably the biggest
thing we could do along those
lines today, by just opening
it up for everyone.
I think this would be obvious
that just the barriers that we
actually put in there on
purpose to make it hard for
people to get in there.
Remember six months ago, you
remember how Wave was like.
At the time we could actually
only scale to about
a few 100,000 users.
had 5 million or so people
wanting to try it out.
So, we put in these barriers.
And, we have just
removed them today.
So, it's a lot easier for you
to get your whole team on Wave.
To get your friends
or family on Wave.
We'll make it even easier in a
couple weeks, where you can
just throw an email address
on a particular Wave.
And, it will get a
link to that Wave.
And they can click it.
And, they'll look at --
I don't know if you pop
that in the keynote.
But, there's a UI now for
Wave, where you just
see that single Wave.
So, it's a lot more.
So,
I get lot less daunting
for new user to look at.
But, really I think we have
definitely learned, and
you guys would have felt
this too, during this
invitation only preview
period, is that we need
to do a lot more work.
Help people understand what
Wave is, and what it's good
for, and how to use
it, and so on.
And, part of that is just
an explanation of Wave.
When we showed Wave first, we
showed this very long demo of
how Wave might one day in the
future play a role in a lot
of different contexts.
And, we put it up there.
And, we have found that very
much the sweet spot the early
use cases that are merging for
waves are all about groups
collaborating on
their projects.
And, so we can know much more,
in a much more focused way,
make those kinds of usage
scenarios work really well.
And, that's what we've
been doing for the
past couple of months.
And, the reason that we are
choosing to open it up at this
point is that increasingly
we're hearing from people that
wow, I was kicking these
tires a while ago.
It looked interesting.
But, now it's actively starting
to get good enough to
get real work done.
The other obvious answer to the
question is that we're going to
try and help you guys build
really cool stuff with Waves
which will get more people
interested in using Waves.
I think for example if the
Embed API takes off, and people
start stumbling over Waves all
around the web, and seeing this
live and incredible, probably
rich engagement with each
other, then that in itself will
draw more people to Wave.
It was something we've
observed with maps.
Which a lot of us
worked on Maps before.
We think that most users
actually saw their first Google
Maps on some other site
that had embedded a Map.
Rather than going to
Maps.Google.com.
PAMELA FOX: I think another
thing that we did was
add the templates.
Because one of the big things
is that users, once they
actually had people on Wave,
they didn't actually know
what to do with Wave.
Because it was, you know, maybe
we weren't clear in the
beginning, or we didn't know
ourselves what is great for.
Right.
So once we figured it out.
We created these templates.
So now when you sign into Wave
you'll see six templates on the
side that's like new document,
new brainstorming, new task
tracking, new event planning.
And those are some of
the people's favorite
use cases of Wave.
And, you know,
somebody signs in
they see that.
And, before maybe they
didn't know what exactly
to do with Wave.
Maybe they're just chatting.
But, now they think, oh
I can use this to track
my meeting notes right.
So I think that templates may
be our going away towards
educating users and getting
them thinking that this is
something they can actually
use and want to use.
STEPHANIE HANNON: And, sort of
a tangent, but I think it's
important on that is we want to
make those templates
customizable.
So, today it's the six we
00:34:41,652 --> 00:34:41,378
pick.
But, you know, our team does
all of our work inside of Wave.
And, if we have a UX review
temple and a production release
kind of template, and all these
different templates we copy
over and over again, and we
want to put those right on the
blank Wave panel so we can
easily initiate them.
And, we also want to let people
hook in their favorite
extensions, so that they just
always want to initiate a Wave
with a certain extension
they can do that easily.
So, I just wanted
to highlight that.
PAMELA FOX: Yeah.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Because I
think the templates we put
there are a basic start.
And they're helping people
figure out what to do
when they get in Wave.
But, for power users we want to
make them more customizable.
AUDIENCE: Hi Jarrod
from Away Fund.
It's really, really awesome
to see that you've opened
it up to everybody.
That was always my issue is I
want to have a Wave, but
there's two people that don't
use it and that's that.
Because were doing
a lot of meetings.
But, at think that Wave has
an incredible potential
for changing the workflow
in organizations.
It's neat that Waves
sort of spread through
Google and teams.
And, I think that it has that
potential to do that, you
know, just in general.
But, I don't think that the
initial experience, even with
templates and with, you know,
a couple of initial Waves
that you get is enough.
Because I think most Google
products kind of takes an
existing metaphor like
email, or maps, or
whatever it happens to be.
And, they sort of change
it a little bit.
But, you sort of have a
paradigm behind you.
Whereas Wave you could sort of
say that about Wiki, but it's
combining a lot of things.
So I'm curious what you're
looking to do to maybe break
outside of some of the way that
Google approach things, in
terms of how you create that
initial experience, you know.
Like if you think of a
traditional web app like I
might create or someone in this
room creates, they probably do
things where they kind of get a
little more in the users face.
And say, do this first, or
invite these people first.
Or, just things that you could
do that I think really educate
the user about how their
workload can change the
potential benefits that go
beyond templates, and pure
text, and even just some of the
videos that you did that you're
about to answer this question.
So, I'm just curious
what you're going
to do to make that experience
educate on workflow.
Because, I think it
could be wonderful.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: So, I think
you actually did a really good
job of describing in some of th
things we're looking
towards doing.
Because we see that people are
using Wave in sort of small
groups to get things done, a
lot of what this means
really is workflows.
But, what kind of happens with
workflow is you have some
people -- and I suspect many of
you in this room -- who sees
something new and powerful, and
sort of broad that you can
do a lot of things with.
And, are able to very quickly
imagine what you can do
with it, and then start
making it happened.
There's the flip side.
There's a lot of people who
when they see something like
that they're frightened.
And, they're like this
is something new.
I don't get it.
I don't want to get it.
I don't want to have to
learn something new.
And, so what we're trying to do
is put the tools in the hands
of the people like you, who
will understand what it is and
have a vision for what it is,
to draw those people in and put
more things in their face.
And, this is how Stephanie
referred to some of the
templates to be able to
create things for them.
But, even more so allowing.
And, so one of the things we
are starting to put a lot more
work into is group support.
So, that you can have full
groups using Wave, and allowing
the person that sets that group
up, to really tailor the
experience for those
users a little more.
And, kind of get them started
and get them on board.
00:37:50,3 --> 00:37:50,124
Because, I
think we can do a lot of things
to explain sort of Wave in
general to people, but I think
the key really is the people
who are heading up those
workflows and projects in
groups, to be able to sort of
set it up for the people to
make it more meaningful
to them directly.
AUDIENCE: Just as a thought.
I feel like you have obviously
a pretty large group
of intelligent people.
And, you have the ability
to really change workflow.
And, I would consider things
like looking how to --
you know, from a machine
learning perspective.
I know you guys have a
whole NLP team with Casey
and all those people.
Like look at what people are
doing, and do something
reactive in response to
that through some sort of
JERP sequence of email.
The idea of -- I know that
Google does a really good
job of sort of getting
out of people's way.
But, I feel like Wave really
can be instrumental in changing
people's behavior in a way that
really reduces redundancy in
organizations, and
creates knowledge.
And, I think you could do that
through JERP sequences in terms
of education overtime, or also
through just figuring out
kind of some patterns and
how they're using it.
And, then doing education
response to that.
It's just different than
other Google products
and you could do that.
LARS RASMUSSEN: I think
you're absolutely right.
And, it is definitely an
area we are still weak in.
Even though we're a little
bit better than in the past.
I don't know if you saw this,
but just this morning, we added
three little tutorials to
that saying Welcome Panel.
If you click one of them,
there's a link below
the templates.
If you click it, it
kind of unfolds.
And, then you click a tutorial
you get a UI where you just
have a single Wave that
we pre-populated.
And, a bunch of simple
steps you can execute
over on the left.
It's still all very
static content.
We are actually working on --
I don't know if I'm suppose
to tell you what we're
working on in this space.
But, we're working on a Robot
of course that we might
actually name it Doctor Wave or
some such thing, that can take
a user through, OK,
now do this and.
And, the Robot connected it
and see if the user does it.
It can see it and
so on, it's --
AUDIENCE: Clippy?
LARS RASMUSSEN: Clippy.
Damn it.
[LAUGHTER]
It looks like you're writing
to it, I don't know.
DAN PETERSON: The human
doctor is getting tired.
STEPHANIE HANNON: OK.
I just wanted to say
one more thing.
In the spirit of helping people
be smarter, work smarter, and
Casey and the NLP team, I think
one area we barely scratched
the surface is the inbox.
And, showing people what's
happening in the inbox and
what's interesting to them.
It's very basic and
it's based on time.
And, I don't want anyone
here to think that we
think that's sufficient.
Like, we know there's
information overload.
And, that was part of the
problem in the early days
of Wave when public
Waves went crazy.
And, every public Wave
you touched showed
up in your inbox.
So, we want to do much smarter
things, because if I'm
explicitly on a Wave it matters
more to me than something I'm
on because of a group.
Something you've replied to or
edited is something I wrote.
It's more important to
me than other things.
If somebody put an ad in
front of my username and a
Twitter-like style probably
directed at me in some way.
So, we just kind of apply some
of the genius engineering on
this team, and to kind of
really presenting you with
information you care most
about in an interesting ways.
DAN PETERSON: Thank you
for the discussion.
So, the next question we'll
grab from moderator.
Will GTalk be updated to have
a new Wave notifier, or have
currently online Wave users
added to the contact list?
PAMELA FOX: Good idea.
Let's do that.
I'm just joking.
We obviously haven't
built it yet.
But I think it's a good idea
and we should probably figure
out how to make it the Waves
integrated with the GTalk.
PAMELA FOX: I want
to talk in Wave.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Okay
DAN PETERSON: Good idea.
Live question.
AUDIENCE: Daniel Grayrosen.
You've talked about this group
collaboration for apps.
Currently it's not possible.
Yeah.
I'm trusting out apps on my
domain as part of the preview.
It seems it's not possible
to send Waves to groups,
or not to other domains
posted at this domain.
So if I have one domain I
cannot send Waves to all
the other domains that
I'm hosting there.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: So, the way
it should work is that if you,
I'll talk to him afterwards.
The way it should work is that
you can add any -- if you have
a domain turned on for Wave,
you can choose to have
it open or closed.
If it's closed it means
your users can only Wave
within their own domain.
And, this is a lot of people
have asked for this
specifically, both in education
to protect students,
that sort of thing.
And, also in businesses to
just make sure they're
not sort of over sharing.
The way it should work though
is also if your domain is open,
you should be able to add
anyone outside your
domain to Waves.
And, it'll show you at the top
of the Wave that someone from
outside of your domain
is on that Wave.
If that's not what you're
seeing, let's talk afterwards.
AUDIENCE: It works that way but
if I'm outside the Wave and add
a group, that's not possible.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Oh, so
you're talking about being
able to add groups --
AUDIENCE: But that's probably
what you're also working on
with the group experience
and whatever.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: So, there's a
number of things that we're
working on with the
group experience.
The very first thing we're
working on is just being able
to follow a group so that
Waves of those groups
go to your inbox.
There also is an interaction
between Wave groups in your
domain versus sort of public
groups and who can
be added to those.
There's kind of a large number
of settings that we're kind of
working through to make sure
all of that's working smoothly.
But, as I said, we're putting
a lot more energy now into
improving the group's support.
Because, this really is sort
of a core part of the Wave
experience for a lot of people.
DAN PETERSON: So, next question
from moderator here is
speed, performance.
What are we doing about
speed and performance?
LARS RASMUSSEN: What
are our goals?
So, speed and performances has
always been a focus of ours.
Will continue to be
a focus of ours.
I don't know if you saw the
graph that flashed by.
But, sort of roughly speaking
speed is about an order of
magnitude better now
than six months ago.
Stability, closer to two
orders of magnitude.
Better we measure it with
metrics like crashes.
Like how many sessions in with
the thing crashing with.
And, it used to be actually in
whole percents, and it's now
down to something like 0.1%.
My hope and aspirations is that
we'll do another order of
magnitude change over the next
six months to a year or so.
It starts getting hard.
A thing we had a real problem
with earlier was the speed
of opening large Waves.
It's very simple, because
we loaded the whole
thing into memory.
We rendered the entire
Wave in the browsers dom,
which was very slow.
And, so just recently, we made
it so that we only render the
part of the Wave that you're
actually looking at.
Sort of an obvious thing to
do, but it was trickier
than we thought.
Because, it's hard to predict
how tall each part of the
Wave is going to be on
until you render them.
A next thing that we're working
on, so apparently when a Wave
gets loaded into the browser,
it's in a format that
specifically tailor it to
making collaborative
editing work.
And, in the browser we
convert that to HTML
to actually show you.
And, we build all of the
data structures to manage
the convert editing.
And, so at some point,
we'll make it so that the
server produces the HTML.
And, we only show the HTML
when you load a Wave.
And, then we only build a
collaborative editing data
structure as if you
actually need them.
And, again, a super
obvious thing to do.
But, quite a lot of
work in practice.
But, I think it's possible to
achieve another order of
magnitude speed improvement
there for sizable Waves.
DAN PETERSON: And there's
actually a talk about, in the
Qwit track actually, about how
Wave has helped, sort of work
through how you can make big
applications fast with Qwit.
So, check the
schedule for that.
AUDIENCE: Once again
about a Gadget API.
What about merging Gadget
states and callback
the state has changed.
Now I know the only
state has changed.
And, I know what is changed.
And I'm doing Gadget is
this whole big documents.
Build a heirarchy
tree, rather big.
And it takes a lot to
merge it to zip it.
And, now I'm using the approach
that I store the document at
the sequence of comments.
It is good for merging but it
takes now a lot of time to
load the ready document.
So, what are your plans,
what are your advice?
DOUWE OSINGA: So basically
you want to have a diff?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I would
like to have a diff.
What have changed in the state?
DOUWE OSINGA: Yeah,
that seems very smart.
AUDIENCE: OK.
00:46:42,55 --> 00:46:42,464
Months, weeks?
[LAUGHTER]
DOUWE OSINGA: Well in a similar
way one thing we have been
wanting for a long time is to
actually give you a diff open
so that when, you know, when th
user comes back to the Gadget,
your Gadget gets a
diff open state.
And can show the user
what has changed, since
he last time looked.
PAMELA FOX: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
STEPHANIE HANNON:
He said weeks.
PAMELA FOX: He said weeks.
DAN PETERSON: We'll grab a
question from up in the laptop.
Yeah.
So, last year you preview
Rosy with Google Wave.
Wondering about some plans for
when Rosy may be available
in the acceptance gallery.
LARS RASMUSSEN: A favorite
question of mind.
Yeah.
So Rosy was actually built by
someone from the Google machine
translation tool, which
is not surprising.
And, I'm not gonna --
this is not someone
who works in my team.
So, it's doubly hard to predict
when it's going to be.
But, I would hope, and
we're talking months here.
One of my favorite Robots ever.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about Wave organizations.
Is it something planned to
have less Wave viewable
at the same time.
I mean I have an idea.
It's something that would
be a mind map, but
with Waves as notes.
That would be something very
useful if you worked on very
large projects that are to be
discussed by several groups of
people, maybe other
things of course.
But, say 100 person
are not to be made as
recipients of one Wave.
DOUWE OSINGA: So, I suppose you
could build something like
that using embedded Waves.
AUDIENCE: Using what?
DOUWE OSINGA: Using
embedded Waves.
AUDIENCE: Embedded Waves, yeah.
DAN PETERSON: So, if I
understand the question though,
what you're saying is you want
to build something mind map
like each note has all the
Wave-like properties to it.
Is that is that kind of
what you're getting at?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's my idea.
DAN PETERSON: So, do that
is what it seems like he's
kind of aiming towards.
We'll discuss it.
PAMELA FOX: Remember at one
point, you know, wanting to
actually visualize your nodes
as a map and seeing the
connections between them.
Is that?
AUDIENCE: OK --
DAN PETERSON: You
need a whiteboard.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
JOCHEN BEKMANN: I'd also like
to say the client that we're
releasing, that source code
can be taken and turned
into something like that.
So, if you have an entirely
different rendering engine and
you want to embed [? LIPS ?]
or Waves in a mind map, you
know, we'd love to see it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah I'd like to.
So just to, I'll try
to make it clearer.
Say someone is creating a Wave,
starting Wave for a big
project, that involves hundreds
of people in a company
of thousands of people.
OK.
Say it took off.
One wave the node of the
mind map would be about
the engine, another about
the wheels, and so on.
PAMELA FOX: Yeah, so I think
that's about connecting the
waves together semantically.
So I was Right.
DAN PETERSON: Pamela
was a right.
PAMELA FOX: So, right now there
are Robots that people are
building to do very basic
structures within Waves like
having, there's task key, you
know, doing sub tasks
and sub task is that.
Which is like a tree.
You're probably looking
for something a little
bit more flexible.
So, I think we've
thought about that.
JOCHEN BEKMANN: You can also
easily do a Wiki like linking
between Waves This is
what we do internally.
Easily.
So, there's a button
linked to this Wave.
You can use that or you can
drag from search panel.
The Wave digest onto
a different Wave
and you have a link to it.
And, if you interlink
them just like --
GREG D'ALESANDRE: But
that being said.
Being able to visualize that
sort of Wiki like structure
easily, is I think a
really interesting idea.
DOUWE OSINGA: So, in my talk if
you also visit this afternoon
I'll show some code on the
Wiki Robot that I've
been working on.
And, of course that thing only
allows you to create new Waves
based on selecting a piece of
text, and then you, you know,
click a button and it creates
a Wave with that thing.
So, it helps you
set up the Wiki.
It would be an awesome thing
to, you know, have that same
Robot then, you know, maybe
maintain one Wave with the
overall structure of
what you have built.
And, you get, I think, so
much close to, you know,
where you're heading at.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: And, in
Alan and my talk tomorrow.
DAN PETERSON: No, Douwe's
talk is at 3 o'clock today.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Yeah, but but
part of the thing we're going
to be showing is exactly the
same sort of thing, but with
also the ability to have Robots
cross updating between these
Waves and these nodes.
Because, I think that's one
of things that we get asked
about all the time is.
It's really interesting to
have sort of a Wiki kind
of a mesh of Waves.
But, what you want to be able
to do is have the information
flowing between them.
And, this is something the
robots, the actual robot
API really enables.
And, I think Pamela
mentioned task key which
does this as well.
So, I think there's a really
interesting aspect there too.
AUDIENCE: Do you mind if
I ask another question?
DAN PETERSON: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: A question
about groups.
I'm working on something
that could give restricted
rights to users OK.
Say I have a Wave with only two
groups as recipients, and one
group is read only, and the
other has full access.
How can I know the group's
other user that is
interacting with the Wave.
DAN PETERSON: So, I think your
question is how do you know
which user is getting
the access through.
Is that essentially?
00:53:24,392 --> 00:53:24,366
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAN PETERSON: Yeah.
PAMELA FOX: If you're looking
to find out stuff about, you
know, what group somebody is
in, or why it is they're able
to view a Wave or edit a
Wave, there's really
nothing like that.
And, there's not really a
Groups API for normal groups.
There is somewhat of an API for
Google Apps Groups, little bit.
But, usually when people are
doing that, I tell them
to create their own
concept of groups.
You know, using App Engine.
I guess your own server now.
So, you really have full
access to the data.
DAN PETERSON: Robots
can configure read
only info access.
PAMELA FOX: Right.
On.
DAN PETERSON: Right.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: So, one of
things that will happen is if
you have access through both
of those groups, you'll get
the highest level of
access that you get.
So, I guess there's
also a question.
It sounds like you want to
know which group its coming
from for another reason.
But, the access levels are
controlled by whatever group
gives you access to the
Wave, if that make sense.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it makes sense.
But, my point was more about
one user belonging to one group
in the two groups that are
recipients of the Wave.
And, so when the Robot reacts
to the user interaction, I
would like to know which
group does he belong to.
PAMELA FOX: Yeah,
I would keep --
AUDIENCE: What are his rights.
PAMELA FOX: I would keep your
own list of groups, and
have your Robot check it.
It's own data store.
DOUWE OSINGA: Yeah.
In this situation, so the user
gets edited away at that point.
So, you could just check what
the access right to the user
has, because tha would be
inherited from the group.
Right.
So, you have one group
that's read only.
So, if the user accesses --
well actually with a [? URL ?]
you can't do anything.
DAN PETERSON: So, actually
we're going to try and wrap
things up a few minutes early
given the crazy schedule
changes that happened
with the keynote.
But, we'll be happy to hang out
here answer questions more of
sort of live and in person.
Or, rather one on one in
person for a little bit.
And, thank you so
much for coming.
We have three
receptions todays.
Three receptions tomorrow.
And, then it's a regular
officer hours and such.
STEPHANIE HANNON: We'll stay
up here and answer questions.
Just, if you want to
remember who we are.
Dan knows everything about
platform and Federation,
Enterprise, whatever we do.
Enterprise, developer
relations, platform,
and then protocol.
So, we'll stay up here
for a few minutes.
And, come talk to us
especially this gentleman
who has more ideas.
Thanks everyone.
Thanks so much for all
your work with Wave.
[APPLAUSE]